[Music]
and the guys welcome to part two of my
flow state series here I'll be
discussing flow hacks you can use to
increase your performance based on what
we established in the previous video if
you haven't watched that part you'll
still be able to benefit from this
though I do recommend checking it out
otherwise let's dive straight into it I
want a quick heads-up first this is now
going to be a three part series in part
three I'll be discussing use of
nootropics tax and transcranial direct
current stimulation to achieve flow but
for now flow hacks so if you're
performing sub-optimally then there are
likely to explanations based on what we
discussed before either you're not
trying hard enough or you're not engaged
enough your mind is wandering or you're
overly stressed second-guessing yourself
and aren't in the moment as a result
this is one where shaking and overly
anxious effective flow hacks should be
aimed at helping you to psych yourself
up when you're distracted and to Center
and ground yourself when you're
panicking so to quickly engage a sense
of calm during intense situations there
are a few things we can do a pathway to
the autonomic nervous system is through
our breathing which helps to stimulate
the vagal nerve one method used by Navy
SEALs to control the fight-or-flight
response is something called box
breathing or foursquare breathing and
what's very interesting is that this
form of rhythmic and controlled
breathing is also very similar to
exercises recommended by the heart math
Institute to induce coherence by
breathing more rhythmically you can also
hopefully make your heart rate
variability pattern more rhythmic and
thereby potentially increase the amount
of DHEA to help you stay in a comely
aroused state to use box breathing you
simply inhale for the count of four
seconds hold for four seconds exhale for
four seconds and then hold for four
seconds again then repeat breathing
through your nose while you're doing
this also help to increase nitric oxide
production which widens blood vessels
and helps improve oxygen delivery to the
brain and apparently humming during this
may further help to enhance the effect
if you find yourself feeling stressed
and making mistakes as a result shaking
and feeling sick try breathing more
rhythmically gently and through your
nose just being more aware of you
breath helps a lot I spoke in a previous
video about another technique you could
use to engage calm called wide-angle
vision this helps to increase present
moment focus by bringing in more visual
information and at the same time
improves reaction times and a state of
calm speaking with several martial
artists stuff and making that video it
seems that this really is one of the
best things you can do to improve your
focus and state of flow during sparring
in particular avoid focusing on limbs
and trying to anticipate the opponent's
movements instead watch their body as a
whole again then when you find yourself
flinching and underperforming try
engaging your peripheral vision and
taking the entire scene in watch my
video on this for more information
apparently relaxing your tongue and
lower jaw can also help to induce the
Karma theta brainwaves are associated
with flow States this makes sense
considering our stereotypical image of
the slack-jawed individual try it now
and you'll find it's much easier to just
zone out but be careful with this
technique if you're in a competitive
sport as it could make you more likely
to clamp your teeth together or bite
your tongue off which will take you
right out of a flow state but really our
stress response is mostly controlled by
our thoughts if you don't believe me
then imagine that you're camping in the
woods and you hear a rustling in the
bush and you know it's a tiger your
heart rate will increase your pupils
will dilate you'll poor with sweat but
then the tiger emerges and it turns out
to be a kitten so it was your
expectation that caused the
fight-or-flight response not the reality
your interpretation of the situation and
the thing is that we imagine Tigers all
around us all the time not literal
Tigers unless you do live in the jungle
but other threats and dangers that
aren't really as bad as we think they
are
for instance when speaking in public you
imagine being booed off the stage if you
stutter but very few crowds are really
that cruel and does it really matter
anyways the difference between being
psyched up for a competition and
experienced performance anxiety is in
your focus are you focused on the event
itself or are you focused on what
everyone will think of you if you fail
this is why sports psychologists the
world over encourage their athletes to
be goal-oriented yes to focus on the
outcome to motivate themselves to work
harder but also to leave their anxieties
in the changing room the best athletes
reportedly view competition as part of
the process rather than being a be-all
and end-all and of course if your brain
is worrying about what the future holds
for you if you fail then it's using up
your cognitive reserves
it would be better employed elsewhere
it's likely that this might lead to
increase activity in the wrong parts of
your brain so stay in the moment and
worry just about doing your very best at
that time this is a common misconception
about flow States in neuroscience
generally but I forgot to touch on last
time that we exhibit one kind of brain
waves across our entire brain or that
neurochemicals affect every brain region
the same in truth it's far more complex
than that and a flow state is like the
result of a complex pattern of brain
waves and neuro chemicals in specific
brain regions you can have alpha
brainwaves in one part of your brain
theta and another gamma in another
achieving flow might be about achieving
excitability in the right places another
piece of useful self-talk is to remind
yourself that your fight-or-flight
response is not a bad thing we've been
conditioned to think of it as a bad
thing and this actually makes us panic
in the wrong way this is why people
experience panic attacks are told not to
try and fight them or suppress them but
to accept them and observe them when you
feel intense stress welcomed it it's
going to help you the adrenaline is
making you stronger and quicker and
heightening your senses studies show
that adrenaline can increase strength by
31% or more your sympathetic nervous
system is not the enemy right now you
could run faster and you are so it's
like you can slow down
what's wrong with scared scared is a
superpower techniques like this an
example of cognitive behavioral therapy
or CBT this is psychotherapeutic
technique that is used by psychologists
to treat conditions like phobia anxiety
disorders an OCD it's my belief that the
same principles can also be applied to
sports psychology productivity and
general performance I plan on doing a
whole video on this soon as CBT has
helped me and others I know immensely
but the basics involve observing your
own feelings and thoughts by using
mindfulness and then cognitive
restructuring techniques to change your
thoughts and your focus to things that
are more conducive to health and in our
case optimal performance
these include techniques such as thought
checking which tests the validity of
your thoughts are people really going to
be off the stage the next time you're in
a situation where you need to perform
optimally try assessing where your focus
is what's on your mind and what is
helping and hindering your performance
remind yourself that your
fight-or-flight response isn't the
threat in itself
remind yourself to breathe remind
yourself to focus on the moment and that
the outcome doesn't matter ask yourself
if your fears are really valid or if
you're inflating them in your mind
with enough practice it may eventually
be possible to control your own
physiological response by being more
sensitive to different changes in your
physiology and your mindset after all
some people are able to trigger an
orgasm with their thoughts alone the
theory is that these individuals are so
in tune with their own feelings and
responses that they can work themselves
up to that state
well that might sound like a random
thing to drop in here my point is that
if this is possible then surely
triggering the flow state is also
possible likewise studies show that
simply being more aware of our heart
rates using biofeedback techniques can
eventually help us to begin to control
them again I'll probably touch on this
more in the future so these techniques
can all help you to find calm the next
time you're in a highly stressed
situation rather than fighting the
increased heart rate embrace it breathe
calmly and become psyched up not psyched
out but after you have the opposite
problem what if your mind is wandering
because you're not engaged enough with
what's happening in that case you have a
few options we've seen already that
breath can be used to control your
autonomic nervous system and as it turns
out that wim HOF method is able to
increase adrenaline more on that soon
you can likewise also use CBT techniques
once again remind yourself why what
you're doing is important and why you
have to win visualize the end goal that
you're striving for and feel the
emotional motivation for why you're
doing whatever it is you're doing in the
first place at the same time and devarti
do your best part of the reason we go
through life in the days is simply that
we aren't challenged enough or engaged
enough if you do the same thing at work
every single day have the same routine
of ironing and making lunch how can you
be expected to engage in the moment or
to perform your best of course in one's
going to wonder again this could be a
matter of thinking about the situation
in the right way if the task is too easy
then try doing it faster or more
perfectly or whilst adding arbitrary
rules and restrictions this is called
gamification going faster or over speed
training as it's also known is a
particularly interesting way to make any
regular task harder and we can see how
this affects cognition by driving on a
motorway at 70 miles per hour then
coming off onto a regular 30 miles per
hour Road how much slower does the
latter see now this is also why the flow
triggers suggested by Steven Kotler such
as deep embodiment which means moving
around a lot rich environments which
not being in a drab office and immediate
feedback could all be helpful they help
to make a task more interesting and
inherently engaging though I do think
his view over simplifies the subject a
lot and you can't always be snowboarding
down a mountain a related concept is all
cultivation seeking out scenes that are
inspiring that could help us to increase
activity across our brains but again
that's a topic for another time you can
also try being more mindful whilst
carrying out tasks mindful washing up is
actually a thing but I prefer mindful
running this just means being more in
the moment focusing on your body as you
perform that task and for more on how to
focus on a creative or productive task
when your mind just wants to wonder
check out my video titled focus ok so
all those techniques can help to remain
karma when you're panicking and to be
more focused when your mind is wandering
these are acute acts that you can use to
help trigger flow in the moment but in
the long term if you want to improve
your ability to focus and to remain calm
then there are few things better than
practicing meditation meditation
essentially involves practicing focusing
your mind whether that means emptying
out or focusing on a mantra or your
breath gradually you'll learn to become
better at ignoring distracting thoughts
and even rising above emotions that
aren't conducive to your optimal
performance combined with mindfulness
this is likely one of the most powerful
tools to help you being greater flow
more of the time though I'd like to
interject at this point and just quickly
remind you that flow is not the only
useful mental state sometimes
daydreaming and activating your default
mode network can be useful for
creativity and long-term planning it's
not always great to be in the moment
there's nothing wrong with being in your
own head this is what makes us human
optimal performance is about being able
to switch between mental states and be
in the right one at the right time
meditation will help to do this you can
also train yourself to deal with stress
better by simply exposing yourself to
extreme stress more often this is the
precise technique used by special forces
to effectively desensitize their
combatants to the stress response Tim
Ferriss recommends doing something
similar by lying down in a public place
to expose yourself to extreme social
pressure
it's embarrassing basically but I can
think of ways that you could be way more
embarrassing in public we also
experienced a stress response when we're
low on oxygen which may be why deep
divers have a similar parasympathetic
response to the special forces and
likewise when we're very cold
I wouldn't recommend trying to train
yourself to
to a sympathetic nervous response by
restricting oxygen but getting outside
of your comfort zone and doing things
that get your heart pumping is
recommended and while doing this
maintain mindfulness and notice how it
feels this is similar to a technique in
cognitive behavioral therapy called fear
testing we expose yourself to your worst
fears and thereby prove to yourself that
they aren't worth fearing practice is
crucial for enhancing your likelihood of
getting into flow if you're still
learning a technique or sport then it'll
take more conscious thought in order to
execute it this is why seemingly
counterintuitive Lee experts and masters
and specific fields actually use fewer
cognitive resources this is called
neural efficiency and it bares
remarkable similarity to flow states of
course every martial artist knows that I
need to practice the same moves over and
over again so that they become second
nature when they need them while
sparring or fighting and when there is
an opportunity I do not hit it hits all
by itself and you can also practice
focus and flow themselves practice
remaining completely focused and in the
moment and you'll become better at
remaining there studies show that neural
efficiency doesn't just apply to
learning skills but also becoming more
efficient in the way that you use your
brain generally by training your working
memory for instance you can increase
neural efficiency across all tasks that
involve nonverbal reasoning again
meditation seems to help in a similar
way so that's an awful lot to take in
but hopefully it's giving you some
interesting topics to research further
practice mindfulness practice being in
the moment start meditating and learn to
control your breathing whilst engaging
wide-angle vision welcomed and use your
physiological response practice your art
and push yourself outside your comfort
zone do all that and you'll be in flow
more often I do think there's a kind of
higher level though you hear a lot of
people who manage to be focused for a
few hours
claiming that they're in flow but I
think everyone chasing flow believes it
can be greater than that we're chasing
those moments where time really slows to
a crawl those rare instances where we
gain seemingly superhuman reflexes and
decision-making I believe that this is
most likely due to an exaggerated
adrenal response I don't know how he
might trigger that at will but
practicing everything we've discussed
here means you'll stand a better chance
of it happening and of being ready when
it does come and of course if you found
this video interesting then please hit
subscribe
so you won't miss out on part three
where I'll be trying out flow state
inducing nootropic stacks and looking at
the role of transcranial direct current
stimulation and what that might mean for
the topic and visit the article that
goes with this video link below there
I'll go into even more depth and include
links to all the studies and reports
touched on here so thanks a ton for
watching guys and I'll see you next time
bye for now